what does it mean to be a featherless
two-legged linguistically conscious
creature born between urine and feces
whose body will soon
be the culinary delight of terrestrial
worms that's what philosophy is all
about
[Music]
every generation of the human species
has to come to terms with i love how to
live how you gonna deal with the
catastrophe how you gonna preserve your
style
[Music]
this class evolves around three
fundamental questions
one
what does it mean to be human terrifying
query two
what are the forms of love that
constitute the best of our humanity
love of truth love of goodness love of
beauty
third how does community
tradition
heritage shape and mold
our conceptions
of who we are as human beings
when you listen to music you have to be
willing to smile when you didn't expect
it or cry when you had no sense of where
your tears come from that's in part what
it means to wrestle with that terrifying
question of what does it mean
to be human and then be willing to get
out of your unique and singular skin
and imagine what it's like
to be in the skin of others
others in every
corner
of
the globe
i am cornell west
and this is masterclass
[Music]
you